lo que me gustaría hacer en este vídeo
es mostrar algunos ejemplos para
identificar la pendiente y la
intersección en y dada una ecuación
entonces comencemos con algo que podemos
reconocer digamos que tenemos algo de la
forma que es igual a 5 x + 3 cuál es la
pendiente y la intersección en y en este
ejemplo bueno ya hemos hablado de que
podemos tener algo en la forma pendiente
intersección donde se tiene la forma que
es igual a la pendiente en la que se usa
la letra m para la pendiente por x más
la intersección en la que se usa la
letra b
entonces si nos fijamos en esto m sería
el coeficiente de x justo aquí m es
igual a 5 esa es la pendiente y b va a
ser este término constante más 3 de modo
que b es igual a 3 así que esta es la
intersección en y eso es bastante
sencillo pero veamos algunos ejemplos un
poco más elaborados digamos que si
tenemos la forma y es igual a 53 x
cuál es la pendiente de la intersección
en que en esta situación
bueno podría haberles tomado 12 segundos
darse cuenta de cómo esta ecuación
anterior es diferente a la que acabo de
escribir aquí no son 5 x son sólo 5 y
esto no es 3 esto es 13 x entonces si
quieren escribirlo de la misma forma que
tenemos allí pueden simplemente
intercambiar 5 y 3 x no importa cuál
esté primero solo están sumando los dos
así que pueden reescribir los ya que ya
es igual a 13 x + 5 y luego podemos ver
claramente que nuestra pendiente es 3 el
coeficiente en el término x y nuestra
intersección en 5 la intersección en
hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que tenemos
la ecuación que es igual a 12 x pausa en
el vídeo y vean si pueden determinar la
pendiente y la intersección en y muy
bien entonces aquí está sucediendo algo
similar a lo que tuvimos aquí en la
forma estándar en la forma pendiente
intersección estamos acostumbrados a ver
el término
x antes del término constante por lo que
podríamos querer hacer eso aquí entonces
podríamos reescribir esto como ye es
igual a menos x 12 menos x + 12 y así a
partir de esto podríamos identificar
inmediatamente el término constante
cuando está en esta forma este es b este
es la intersección con la intersección
en que está justo aquí pero cuál es mi
pendiente bueno la pendiente es el
coeficiente en el término x pero lo que
vemos aquí es un signo negativo
cuál es el coeficiente bueno podemos ver
a menos x como si fuera lo mismo que
menos 1 x de modo que la pendiente a que
iba a ser menos 1 hagamos otro ejemplo
digamos que tenemos la ecuación y es
igual a 5 x cuál es la pendiente y la
intersección en que al principio
podríamos decir que esto no se parece en
nada lo que tenemos aquí sólo tengo un
término en el lado derecho del signo de
igualdad aquí tengo dos pero simplemente
podemos ver esto como 5 x + 0
puede llamarles la atención que nuestra
intersección en g es igual a 0 y nuestra
pendiente es un coeficiente en el
término x es igual a 5
hagamos un ejemplo más digamos que
tenemos que es igual a menos 7 cual es
la pendiente y la intersección allí
bueno una vez más podríamos decir que
esto no se parece a lo que teníamos aquí
arriba como calculamos la pendiente y la
intersección en y bueno podríamos
desarrollar una idea similar podríamos
decir que esto es lo mismo que ya es
igual a 0 por x menos 7 y ahora se
parece a lo que tenemos aquí y puede que
identifiquen que nuestra intersección en
jr es menos 7 la intersección en g es
igual a menos 7 y nuestra pendiente es
un coeficiente en el término x es igual
a cero y eso tiene sentido para un
cambio dado en x se esperaría un cambio
0 njei porque ya es siempre menos 7 en
esta situación